Eccolo qua Ah sì sto Diamante
rosa sembra abbastanza facile Fammi
vedere questa guardia
siamo diventati dei ladri Guardate come
siamo vestiti Infatti siamo vestiti
tutti di nero perché
tu provi subito col tuo turno
mi ha lasciato il vestito da ladro nero
varagon è arrivata perché non sapevo
neanche il cerchietto Comunque questa è
una nuovissima Escape Room in cui
dovremo provare a rubare il diamante
abbiamo derubare questa gioielleria
senza essere scoperti Secondo voi saremo
bravi o non saremo bravi c'è un furgone
lì c'è qualcuno che aspetta vicino al
furgone sì quelli sono i nostri amici
ladri che stanno aspettando che noi
andiamo lì a metterci d'accordo Eh sì
dobbiamo anche escogitare un piano per
derubare questa gioielleria gigantesca
Guarda c'è tipo un diamante gigante cioè
la finestra a forma di Diamante Oh Che
spettacolo sono dei soldi che fluttuano
poi lasciate un bel mi piace e mi piace
in questa Escape Room Vi porterà fortuna
in
vi porterà tanti nuovi
diamanti abbiamo parlato con Paolo Paolo
dove l'hai letto il nome Paolo il palo
No quello che fa il palo
e lasciamo pure rubare il negozio di
gioielli Spero sul furgone raggiunge il
tetto Ah vuol dire dobbiamo salire sul
furgone a raggiungere il tetto là sopra
Spero sul furgone come speso Ah ok
Aspetta hai visto si possono prendere i
soldi sono pieni no Ciao ciao a
superarmi eh Ahia sono rimaste castrato
aiuto aiuto aiuto c'è la testa per il
corpo è rimasto lì aiuto aiuto aiuto
allora ecco andiamo anche a Note
fluttuanti Oh non ti prendere tutti i
soldi eh Attento a non cadere qua stecca
di qua e la fine la
Allora vedi che sei tu che sei una
schiappa non so non è colpa mia No
Guarda vedi vedi che è facile vedi che è
facile uh uh uh
ah ah ah ah
quindi dobbiamo entrare nella
gioielleria dal tetto non Dalla porta
principale ovviamente perché altrimenti
ti sbattono Subito Ecco un'altra
banconota fluttuante presa Guarda che
sono dietro di te non portarti a
spingermi rimani lì dove sei fermo fermo
fermo Ok ce l'ho fatta attenzione alla
pupù di uccello sul tetto Ah ah ah gli
uccellini Sono sono dei dinosauri Uh
vuol dire cacca in inglese quindi
attenzione alla cacca di uccello sul
tetto dove si sale e sono già quassù
guarda mi vedi oh oh ne approfitti del
fatto che sono entrata Ecco cosa carina
Wow Quando Salvi ti dà altri soldi
Ma questi uccelli sono tipo dei
dinosauri giganti
quante ne hai Io ne ho 16 di 250
Anch'io ne ho 16 però sono appena
sfracellato sulla su queste cose fumanti
Chissà se riusciremo a prendere tutte
250 e questo è difficilissimo da
prendere guarda
sono riuscita rischio sfracellamento
proprio Ecco qua c'è un altro alleato
amico ladro salta dalla finestra Aspetta
mi sto continuando a sfrigellarmi qui
non so come si fa tranquillo tanto qua
dovrei sfracellarti per forza perché
dobbiamo entrare dalla finestra con la
gioielleria aiuto Comunque ricordati che
noi siamo ladri dovremmo fare molto in
silenzio dovevo fare piano altrimenti
arrivano le guardie Ok allora qui ci
sono altri soldi Ma mmm aspetta Forse
qui c'è un passaggio segreto delle scale
No devi saltare
dalla finestra
Ah ah ah
filadel attenzione perché fai laser se
tu li tocchi non solo ti sfracelli ma
arriveranno anche le guardie Davvero Sì
quindi non bisogna proprio toccarli tipo
Mission Impossible però dobbiamo ancora
provate
sapete che io
stavo per dire che io mi sfracello con i
laser ma a quanto pare Vitale sui social
non so come ho fatto a sfracellarmi
ma abbiamo superato il primo passaggio
della gioielleria abbiamo superato i
laser
aspetta Non svegliare la guardia attento
ai laser blu c'è una guardia che dorme
lì Non svegliarlo ok e tocchi laser blu
si sveglia e ci mettono in prigione
sembra abbastanza facile
stavo fatto all'inizio Invece qua Vedi
allora piano piano credo che sia stata
colpa mia perché ho toccato un pezzo blu
eh eh
no no Devo provare a Non svegliare
questa qua guarda viene a salvare prendi
le banconote prendi le banconote vedi
laser che si muovono Sì qua bisogna
stare super attenti
Ok Wow È fighissima questa Skin proprio
vediamo ho vinto mi ha aspettato un
laser mi ha affettato eh Posso prendere
queste statue no l'estate
vuoi prendere l'estate
pure attentato No Ancora ho visto un
altro che venivo affettato
dai se
ce la puoi farcela Anche tu per ora
Anita ladra in testa oh oh oh in testa
yeah Ok ce l'ho fatta non ce n'è altri
laser qui banconote banconote qua al
posto dei laser Ci sono tipo dei fari
che controllano se sta passando qualcuno
Quindi non farti prendere da questi non
fare Ok ce l'ho fatta Vediamo
anche questo banconota
allora che dice il nostro amico qui
Questa porta è chiusa I ragazzi hanno
scavato un tunnel attraverso il locale
caldaia Wow ma sono bravissimi i nostri
amici che altro i nostri amici ladri
vogliono vedere come protegge
[Musica]
per terra io 57 58 e tu 59 no
andiamo a superare devo prenderle tutte
sei stato 3 riprovo perché mi sono
stronnellato attenzione alla lava
abbiamo scavato molto in basso non
dovevate scavare così
tutto il centro della terra praticamente
oh ecco allora ehm Allora bisogna stare
attenti alla lava Non capisco dove
dobbiamo parlare
no di qua no
Dove bisogna andare Ah ecco bisogna
andare qua guarda non ci credo che l'hai
visto per voi No ho sentito qualcuno che
veniva a bruciacchiato
eri tu a carbonizzata dalla Lava e io
invece sono in vantaggio pianissimo devo
prendere le misure bene
ti dico Avanti qua è un pochettino
difficile Anita
avanti
ci sono queste strutture di ferro che
sono tipo galleggianti sopra la lava non
so come si proteggono lo stesso si
muovessero saremmo già caduti vengono
con il gas della lava eh eh eh oh non ci
credo mi hai superato adesso ti butto
giù adesso ti prendo tutte le volte alla
fine eh stavo parlando del gas
stiamo risalendo sopra No non è ancora
finita però queste strutture fluttuanti
[Musica]
a prendere Ehi sei riuscita a prendere
questa banconota passare avanti cioè
Vediamo ce l'ho fatta anch'io a
prenderlo Wow
ciao ciao ciao ciao
Ale e in vantaggio
come hai fatto arrivare già lì perché
sono molto forte un'altra banconota sono
77 tu
Io sono 83 Ah ah ah
dai 3 2 Questo è un tipo di esempio
antico Ma domani è più antico
maledetto Wow
successo dove andiamo a prendere questa
banconota
aiuto Non voglio cadere giù Guarda
quanto siamo in alto Scusa che cosa
c'entra il tempio antico con la banca
coi gioielli la gioielleria non hai
capito c'è qualche segreto strano in
questa gioielleria Ciao
sono questi li ho presi io Ciao ciao
trappola No io sono ancora vivo Guarda
guarda
Dove sei Riesci a vedermi no come come
hai fatto solo per favore Forse riesco a
salire Vediamo prova No
[Applauso]
dai Non è così difficile puoi farcela
Ecco Vitale lì ce la farà ce la farò di
qua Ok allora devo Saltare su questi e
Oh guarda banconota
Katy Peggio per te
Guardate dove dobbiamo entrare adesso
aspetta aspetta aspetta Ma questo vuol
dire che poi quello ci mangerà e
dovremmo uscire da quella parte lì
quella che conosciamo tutti e sappiamo
che abitare non piace non lo so lo
scopriremo molto presto Vediamo Aspetta
vediamo se c'è qualche banconota
vediamo vediamo Wow È stato proprio
interessante questo tempio soldi che
dice vai dobbiamo uscire da qui ok Eh sì
l'avevamo capito è un Escape Room ora
dobbiamo anche rubare i diamanti dove
sono Eh sì aspetta anche qui ho lasciato
delle banconote Non voglio mica essere
superato da Anita
forse ti supera Io sono accento e
104.1
il coso
vediamo
come faccio a cadere
sono in testa sono in testa sì non è
giusto Anita è pieno di trappole qua
preparati ok
Sto cercando di capire Ah qua devo
saltare qua sopra poi qua Wow fighissimo
passare questa
dai puoi farcela lasciate un mi piace
per portare fortuna Vitale Dai dai dai
dai dai Lasciatelo Lasciatelo Uh uh ce
l'ho fatta ma funziona Allora funziona
per davvero Ecco venite vediamo se
Vitale capisce il meccanismo di questa
nuova trappola Ma sembra un mulino E
certo che lo capisco
boh no Poverino
è caduto giù e qua c'è una pianta
gigante non c'entra niente con la
pioggia con la banca non c'entra niente
nemmeno con la gioielleria e nemmeno con
un tempio Paus adesso così allora
vediamo dobbiamo ancora passare un'altra
volta
stranamente sono ancora viva
Vitale Fra poco ti raggiungerà il tesore
passerà ma eh eh dove dobbiamo andare
qui sulla pianta dobbiamo salire sulle
foglie siamo in acqua
Avete visto Vitale la zucca nere Ecco
mia Anita Eccomi Ah finalmente ce l'hai
fatta
per raggiungerti
attento al Burger davanti a te
lo so che cos'è vuol dire
ciao ciao gigante che vuole spiaccicarci
Oh aiuto
e praticamente bisogna salire Ah attento
devi salire qua e poi nasconderti perché
passa questa palla gigante con le
spiaccicarsi
nello specifico qua resta qua Ok ora
via via che è successo mi sono
sfracellato mille volte tipo
anche a me credo dai concentrazione
possiamo farcela ladro Vitale attento
sono inciampato sono rimasto steso è
passato la palla ha fatto mi spiaccicato
spianatino
per Vitale puoi farcela
Eccolo qua Allora il 25 giorni dopo è
arrivato
Dove siamo qui abbiamo scavato
attraverso il muro velocemente super la
scala Eh stiamo tornando nella
gioielleria è il momento giusto uh uh
banconote qua se non fossimo passati
oltre
Brava brava brava stiamo tornando nella
gioielleria che hanno sparso tutte
queste banconote qui non si capisce e
forse è una trappola Non lo so
stiamo tornando nella gioielleria ha
deciso di provare i diamanti adesso ma
con tutti questi soldi non ce lo
possiamo comprare il diamante e no non
bastano perché costano troppo attenzione
io arresto in anticipo cosa filo arresto
in anticipo e Google Translate Pensa che
voglio dire filo Eh come si chiama
quello a filo spinato
Io ho preso tantissime banconote €141
Clicca sul lavandino ha dispiaciuto per
aprirla
la valigia di sfiato mi piace tantissimo
Wow
un'altra banconota è così avanti
rispetto a me Ehi tu che sei un po'
schiappa oggi
e più immagini il creatore non potrebbe
essere più creativo Ok Che cosa non hai
capito niente
non sapete parlare l'italiano
Allora qualcuno ha messo qua un non so
come si chiama questo aggeggio qua per
bloccare la pentola così potete passare
quindi siamo tutti amici con gli altri
ladri siamo collaborando benissimo
collaboriamo collaboriamo sono rimasto
alle elettrizzato
Ma anch'io l'ho toccato ma non mi ha
letrizzato come mai forse io ho toccato
il cavo ho sbagliato allora
[Musica]
ho capito scusami eh vita le sfracellino
dietro io nel frattempo continuo a
prendere No
un sacco di rose
[Musica]
devo dire che la sicurezza
allora questa gioielleria c'è fin troppa
sicurezza attento perché nella prossima
stage ci sono i laser che si muovono
velocemente
Wow sono riuscita a salvare Non ci credo
io invece sono rimasto indietro
tantissimo e continua a sfrocellarmi in
testa sento una guardia in testa
tipo sulla testa così ecco Vitale oh oh
c'è un accordo voglio portare i laser
provo quel laser mi stava prendendo dai
super Attento attento
Ah
è stato facile dai Presto dobbiamo
prendere i canali dobbiamo prendere i
gelati
Io penso sempre solo una cosa Eh c'è una
guardia lì
Forse è meglio se ci nascondiamo
non è molto intelligente questa guardia
perché si sbatte alle scrivaniette
Quindi bisogna
distrarla Ok dov'è Non la vedo più eh
Dov'è finito Vabbè io nel frattempo
chiudo prendo le banconote questo ho
trovato la via d'uscita lo sai C'è
un'altra banconota qui devo prima
prendere le banconote Ecco la guardia là
dietro
[Musica]
io ho 175 banconote vero 176 ah ah ah ah
ah ah
scusa ti ho spinto io forse Eh adesso ti
spiego io Hai capito
io a te
come è possibile che sei avanti
E allora io me ne vado Oddio no Dove sei
Anita
che è successo i diamanti raccogliamoli
tutti ma possiamo prendere tutti quelli
che vogliamo Aspetta vediamo che dice il
nostro amico Clicca il vetro per rubare
i gioielli uh uh Ok clicchiamo a
Monterosso Diamante Celeste Diamante
giallo Diamante rosa è il mio colore
preferito Poi ho preso un segnale
invisibili avanti collane di diamanti
Diamante Nero Diamante verde diamante
rosso Diamante bianco
e ora che cosa succederà verrà la
polizia a prenderci Non lo so non penso
che riusciremo a farla Franca
Antonio Gigante Qui non l'abbiamo preso
Oh questo qui
prendete quattro gigante Prendilo devi
saltare e cliccare Wow
l'allarme l'allarme dobbiamo scappare
Sta arrivando la polizia la polizia sta
venendo a prenderci troppo
presto preso
dove
sono queste scarpe Non capisco Comunque
ok
Non lo so La polizia la Polizia ha
trovato non riesco a passare Ah ecco ce
l'abbiamo ancora nascosta qua dentro
Guarda devo prenderla per superare vita
devo stare in vantaggio qua dietro Wow
presa anche un'altra
Salviamo in vantaggio prima che arrivi
la polizia Oh scappa Wow È bellissimo
Un'altra banconota
ma è tipo il pavimento è tipo di
petrolio che cosa sta succedendo qui
usciamo da qui dice ok va bene
Qua ci sono dei diamanti
questi sono altri diamanti dove Questi
sono i diamanti che abbiamo perso
che succede Ehi ma forse
ho preso il peggio Io non so se ho preso
invece ho preso il Belgio di averlo
preso non lo sai tu non ti vedo tornare
indietro ora l'abbiamo fatta verifica la
nostra nuova missione
importante che siamo riusciti a rubare
tutti di amore lasciate un bel mi piace
e vi lasciamo Qua quattro casellini su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri video
cliccate su quello che preferite eh
Buona visione Ciao
200 contro 2003 ho vinto